sam hewitt
gearing up to star alongside the one and
only celine dion
uh in the upcoming rom-com text for you
and couldn't help but gush all about our
canadian queen during an appearance i'll
watch what happens live take a look and
happy march break for everyone who's
taking a week off and marlo thank you
next time bye bye i mean i'll see you
here next week but
see you
i'm i'm a marketer so i'm doing this new
movie with celine dion and it's her
first how's her acting debut right now
what an
she's incredible but she's not only
in the movie and she's really good and
she's extremely funny but she's also
supplying the music for the movie wow
written a song especially for us so uh
great and what's the kookiest thing she
did um
she is a coke
in the best way
she's a she's a cook no she's she was
amazing honestly she's really good mom
and she's a good human yeah yeah yeah
yeah really good human being she's a
great i can't wait for you guys to see
it she's brilliant and the music is
spectacular